what's going on there citizens of the
reject nation greg here john just showed
up at my door shawn how you doing i'm so
good good i'm glad to hear you're good
guys guys i got a couple of text
messages today when it's text that's
serious of people saying did you see the
ghost rider easter egg in the new
she-hulk featurette and i says nay
haven't seen that featurette yet and
what
there's a ghost rider easter egg in here
somewhere is there gonna be a ghost
rider cameo in this show you're going to
be a character finally returning in
she-hulk legal trouble
so it's like easy to miss blink and
you'll miss kind of deal so i'm going to
be on the lookout for that but i also
hear the featurette in and of itself is
actually really great so ladies and
gentlemen please leave a like that is so
appreciated doesn't take a lot of work
on your end don't be lazy leave that
like also this is a part of
shopzeroedition.com and if you guys ever
end up wanting to support us by checking
out our awesome merch over there and tag
us on social media when you're rocking
the gear let's get to it
[Music]
jennifer walters is an attorney who has
accidentally taken in the hulk's blood
and has become like a chick hole a
she-hulk exactly
that's got a nice ring to it that name
better not stick
there's something so surreal and so
funny about a giant six foot seven hulk
in the
courtroom it was about putting a real
human being into these absurd situations
oh cool just like as cool and edgy as we
can get away with girl your ass looks
crazy right now
it's something that you think you knew
which is law shows
and something that you think you know
which is marvel shows yeah smash
together get that wrong
this show is so much fun it all has this
tongue-in-cheek self-referential thing
going on in the comics she broke the
fourth wall and was super meta
i just want to make sure that you don't
think this is one of those cameo every
week type of shows well except bruce
and blonsky
and mom
time becoming a absolutely and this idea
of being a superhero
is not appealing to her
being a superhero is a trial by fire
oh i'm not a superhero i just want to be
a normal anonymous lawyer that's not
going to happen no going back to what
you were before
who's going to protect the world
if not people like you
this is expanding the definition of what
a marvel studios production can be
that's cool to hear this is a radical
revolutionary show can we get some shots
please it's an emergency
[Music]
where's that ghostbuster
is it in that like alleyway moment with
the three goons or something hold on let
me play this back a little bit we gotta
look even closer what where is it i mean
i really like that i got a bunch of
thoughts off of this we're definitely
jump cutting around here guys just a
little heads up this is not real time it
hasn't been here a while 10 minutes
later i found it
the johnny blaze easter egg right there
yes
it looks like it's an actual johnny
blaze show this looks like where he's at
where wong's breaking through is he like
a magician in this
i'm not sure what's going on here that
definitely says johnny blaze right yeah
definitely says blaze and it's enough
letters to be johnny it looks like a com
like they've already cast their johnny
blaze of maybe holy crap who is that you
can't make that who that is
back oh that's crazy and it looked like
some of the the creatures were the same
creatures from the chongqi movie wong's
gonna be fighting them and he's gonna be
so heavily involved in here but dang
that's wild so he's like man i'm sorry
i've had so much doubts about that whole
hearing about you know the thing
possibly cameoing in here but the fact
that if this looks like we're going to
see an actual johnny blaze because it
seems like this is the show that wong is
breaking through the curtains or at
least there's like no one here in the
audience maybe it's a rehearsal or
something like that yeah and there are
hell things happening in this scenario
that wong needs to intervene upon so
it's not a big leap to imagine that
maybe some supernatural nefarious
business is going down yeah
i mean i love this feature right moving
past the excitement of that took a long
ass time
moving past the excitement of that i
gotta say that like everything that i've
ever heard from from my friends who are
all big fans of the comics of she-hulk
they say that like this really feels
like she-hulk and then seeing what these
creators behind the series are talking
about and it's really easy to do that
you've seen that with a lot of movies
and shows that have utterly failed
before and don't represent what they say
they're drawing inspiration from but the
vibes that i'm getting seem like for the
most part obviously there's some
different stuff going on here in terms
of origin and whatever she still could
have been shot and then that's why bruce
had to give her some of his blood from
the trailers that it sent me from a car
crash accident but i feel like maybe the
gunshot thing happened probably
beforehand i just don't want to put them
in trousers it might be too dark but as
it stands you know like the breaking of
the fourth wall the personality the life
even the the cameos like she said
marvel i feel like intentionally put
that in the trailer to go i don't want
you to think that that way we can have
surprises because we we already know
daredevil is going to be in here that's
already confirmed the last trailer
showed us we know of course emil blonsky
wong all the other rumors and
considering what her job is and who she
has to be representing what the she-hule
character is just seems like we're going
to be getting you know
more cameras maybe even multi-verse
so i i don't know i don't know but yeah
as it stands i i really thought this
featurette was pretty awesome pretty
hyped for this show have felt just so
sincere and everything is trying to do
so yeah i'm really really looking
forward to it i couldn't agree more and
it's just nice to see like how much love
and faith they seem to be putting into
this show especially like kevin feige
talking about it yeah just the more we
see from it the more excited i become
and everybody has been talking about the
effects but even that too like
especially on she-hulk herself the more
i see of that the more i just sort of
start to lose it into you know the
character and i think that's a really
cool thing because there are characters
covered in prosthetics where you see the
prosthetics and then you're sort of like
i'm aware they're there but the content
is good enough that i'm looking past
that and i feel like that'll be the
effect ultimately with some of the cgi
if it you know is noticeably cg'd or
whatever but yeah like i love how much
of the spirit they seem to be leaning
into and i'm sure people are going to be
like oh you're trying to get in on
daredevil but like she-hulk was breaking
the fourth wall before that
um and so yeah i don't know this looks
like a really lovely translation of what
the source material is and it looks
really fun and it also looks like it has
potential to be
something very satisfyingly
interconnected in a very obvious way
that might get people a bit more on
board with the overall phase four as
well so amen to that sister john
alrighty guys well what did you think
about this did you catch that upon first
viewing because if no one told me about
it that would have completely flown over
my head subscribe click that
notification bell leave a like there's
so much marvel stuff to talk about right
now it's just a marvel week that's what
this is let's end this with a
michael b omnimedia michael you've been
killing it lately dude i saw that on
your channel you finally watched the
movie logan loved your reaction i know
even i we get that a lot when we have a
first time watching my end i was like
wow can't believe you haven't seen this
movie yet especially with how much more
you have seen than both john and i
combined
i'm so surprised you haven't seen it yet
it's a great reaction i highly recommend
you guys go watch it michael is
constantly killing it he's actually a
really good friend of ours as well
please show your support at part of this
reaction review community i do think
he's one of the best and will be
absolutely one of the biggest as long as
this man stays consistent i mean that
with the utmost sincerity so give this
man a follow talk with y'all soon
[Music]
you